Yesterday, we did an entire story about the
75 year old protester, Martin Goodnow, who
was attacked by Buffalo police shoved on to
the ground, hit the back of his head, caused
bleeding from his ear.
Now, I'm not going to give you that full story
again because we just did it yesterday.
But the big shock since yesterday is that
Donald Trump's press secretary, Kaley McKenny,
has doubled and tripled down on Donald Trump's
attacks of the protester, not of the police.
What we.
I'll go back a little bit.
Yesterday, Donald Trump tweeted about this
altercation, quote, Buffalo protesters shoved
by police.
Could be.
And TFR provocateur.
Seventy five year old Martin Guggi.
Snow was pushed away after appearing to scan
police communications in order to black out
the equipment.
Oh, when I watched, he fell harder than was
pushed.
Was aiming scanner could be a setup.
So this was where did Trump get this?
As he says, this is a story from O.J. and
which is a wacky it's even crazier than Fox
News.
They did a segment promoting these baseless
conspiracies.
Trump bought it hook, line and sinker.
It was sick.
So yesterday, Trump's press secretary, Haley
McInerney, is asked about this on Fox and
Friends, and she doubles down with a complete
trash response.
Let's take a look at it.
Yes, say the president, Kelly, was tweeted
out that this Buffalo protester, the 75 year
old who was shoved to the ground by a police
officer, might have been part of an teper
and a provocateur in order to get that type
of reaction.
Just to paraphrase.
Could you expand on that?
Does the president think that this this guy
is part of an TIFA?
So the president was raising questions based
on a report that he saw other questions that
need to be asked in every case.
We can't jump on one side.
OK, so I want to interrupt us for a moment.
Trump was asking questions based on the report
he saw.
The report he saw was a completely speculative,
irresponsible segment from a channel called
A.N., which Trump increasingly loves because
they kowtow to him 100 percent of the time
rather than 98 percent of the time, which
is what Fox News does.
It's a segment which asserted no facts whatsoever.
It was mere speculation that she says, is
the basis for Trump's tweet.
Let's continue every case.
We can't jump on one side without looking
at all the facts at play.
This individual had some very questionable
tweets, some profanity laden tweets.
OK.
I have to stop again.
Kaley McKenny says 75 year old Martin Guggi
know who was attacked by police, tweeted questionable
things that had Suares.
Let's just apply basic critical thinking.
Did the officers interacting with Guggi know
know about his tweets when they knocked him
down, causing him to bleed out of his ear
and putting him in the hospital for nearly
a week?
Of course they didn't.
They didn't know who he was.
And most importantly, most importantly, tweeting
swearwords doesn't mean that it's warranted
for police to knock you over and put you in
the hospital.
Right.
I thought this was America.
This is disgusting.
The president's press secretary asserting
as a defense of Trump, attacking the protester
that the protester once tweeted questionable
things with swear words, if you can imagine
anything more milquetoast.
This is a tragedy.
Let's continue some profanity laden tweets
about police officers.
Of course, no one condones any sort of violence.
We need the appropriate amount of force used
in any interaction.
There are a lot of questions in that case.
In fact, you had fifty six police officers
who resigned in protest of how their fellow
officers were treated.
So there is the grand finale.
We're all disgusted that so many officers
resigned in defense of the cops who did this.
But Kaylee is citing the resignations as proof
that the officers were in the right.
The reality is that Buffalo PD has a very
long history of this type of get in line no
matter what they've done, sort of nonsense.
And that's exactly what we're seeing here.
It's horrifying that Trump even stepped into
this by tweeting things that were antagonistic
of the protester and now his press secretary
is doubling down.
Then she was asked about it again during her
press briefing.
So the clip I showed you is from Fox in the
morning yesterday.
Then she did a press briefing starting about
45, 50 minutes late and she tripled down.
Let's take a look at that.
So much regret tweeting out a faceless conspiracy
theory about a 75 year old protester on the
morning George Floyds funeral.
The president was asking questions about interaction
and a video clip he saw.
And the president has the right to ask those
questions.
Regret tweeting out.
This protester was assaulted.
The president does not regret standing up
for law enforcement men and women across this
country.
So here Kaylie tries to make it about Trump
standing up for law enforcement.
This actually weakens law enforcement.
I.
This is really an important.
This is not a trivial matter here.
When law enforcement does something so obviously
wrong and the president defends it, it reduces
trust in law enforcement, which worsens the
situation on the ground.
If Trump actually criticized the officers
here, it would increase trust that when law
enforcement so obviously misbehaves, there
will be agreement that they misbehaved.
We all lose.
When Donald Trump does this.
And just one more piece of this clip about
so-called facts, again, coming up, rather,
to have facts before he tweets anything.
He's the president of the United States.
The president did have facts before he tweeted
out that undergirded his classless conspiracy
theory.
Is not baseless conspiracy?
No, not at all.
I won't acknowledge that because, look, you
had.
Let's contrast this to the George Floyd situation,
which that horrific video that we all saw.
Every single police officer that I saw across
the country came out and said, this is an
inexcusable action and I condemn this police
officer in this case.
There were 57 police officers who said I resign
in protest.
So, again, with the police officers who resigned
who actually should be ashamed of themselves.
But more importantly, Kaley McKenny says Trump
did have facts when he tweeted and repeated
those attacks against 75 year old Martin Guggi.
No, he did not.
All Trump had when he tweeted about this,
attacking Martin Guggi, no worthy, baseless,
conspiratorial assertions of an O.J. in segment.
This is sick.
And remember that there is a I don't want
to call it a strategy, but there is a political
impact to this, which is that sowing division
is good for Trump.
If he can get people doubting who's good and
bad, even in such an obvious interaction as
the one that Martin Guggi know had with police.
If people can be arguing about, well, you
know, whose side are we on that prevents people
from uniting about anything?
And that is exactly what Trump needs.
Trump needs a divided country so that they
don't unite and realize it's obviously time
for a change.
It's obviously time for a change in November.
Let's not fall for it.
Quick reminder, chess tournament.
David Pakman Show Chess Tournament Tuesday,
June 16 at 8:00 p.m. Eastern.
I hope you will join.
I hope you will play.
We did this once before.
Had 500 participants.
Let's go for a thousand.
But we will be doing the tournament on the
Web site.
Lead.
Chess dot org.
L.A. chess story.
This is all free.
You're invited.
It's free to everybody.
I'll be streaming the tournament.
And anybody who wants to play can play all
skill levels.
Welcome.
Tuesday, 8:00 p.m., June 16th.
Remember to get the David Pakman show daily
podcast on whatever podcasting app you prefer.
I iTunes, Stitcher, Google Play, Spotify,
all of those are available.
And lastly, let me know what you make of this
entire Martin Fujino thing.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman and I look
forward to hearing from him.